[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Sam Rockwell three
Billboards outside eing Missouri when I
was 8 years old I was called into the
principal's office and my father was
looking very cem and he said we got to
go it's Grandma and we got in the car
and I said uh what's wrong with Grandma
and he said nothing we're going to the
movies my mom and dad's love of movies
became my love of movies so thank you
for that Mom and Dad I love you thank
you the formidable Francis mcdorman
we're at the convention Francis
fantastic Woody harelson you guys are my
heroes this the rest of this incredible
cast and crew Martin MCD I wouldn't be
standing here if it wasn't for you Ronda
Elise Jason Liz Mahoney Liz hilstein
Terry nicker Bacher all my good friends
and my beloved Leslie bib You Light My
Fire baby I love
you for my old buddy Phil hofman